- All right! So in the audience,
we have some more questions
for New Kids today.
So what's your question, Kelly?
- Hi!
- [Kelly] Hi!
- Some of my favorite memories
have been going on the cruises.
They've been the best times of my life
and I've met so many amazing
friends because of you guys.
But I know Blockheads can
be a little bit crazy,
so I'm wondering what is one
of your wildest fan encounters
that you've ever had?
- [Donnie] Well, we have a lot of 'em.
(audience laughs)
But since you mentioned the cruise,
I'm gonna mention one,
because you're part of our cruises
even though you're not on them.
Because our fans, they change
lyrics of songs to our names.
For example,
- Oh...
if your song "Since You
Been Gone" ever comes on,
it becomes, (sings) "Since you Been..."
- [Audience] (sings) Jon.
(audience and participants laugh)
- Oh my god.
- (sings) Since You Been Jon!
3,000 people singing that, it's amazing.
You gotta be there.
- Yeah, you gotta be there.
- You gotta come next time.
- Honestly, I'm never
gonna since that song again
without thinking about you.
(everyone laughs)
That's amazing! Oh my god.
- You'll never sing without Jon again.
Look, our fans are crazy,
but we say that lovingly.
We don't want them to be
referred to as bad-crazy.
They're amazing-crazy.
- Normal people are boring.
- Really, they're all fun.
Yeah, that's right.
- Yeah.
- Blockheads are the
best, and their our heart.
But, there was a time,
I think we're in Santiago, Chile,
in 1991 we were doing the
Amnesty International Festival
and it's Sting, and Sinead
O'Connor, and Jackson Brown,
and all these amazing artists...
and the New Kids.
(audience laughs)
They had just been liberated
from Augusto Pinochet,
and it was a really big to-do.
Our fans were going crazy,
and when we got out of the airport,
the hundreds of thousands
of fans at the airport,
they finally got us to the bus.
We had to walk through people,
over people, under people.
It was crazy.
But as we were driving away,
there was continuous banging.
We were literally miles from the airport,
and there were fans on top of
the bus, banging on the bus.
We saw hands coming through the skylight.
(audience chuckles)
- Okay, I really like-
- Just, the levels of love.
- Meryl Streep, but I'm
never gonna climb on her car.
(audience and participants laugh)